Lily.
Amit, how are you?
Good.
Good, good.
We can provide and join, are they gonna come for build it this year?
I'm just checking.
Hello, Lee.
Yeah.
No, actually not. I think Kris is traveling somewhere. So during that time, so he won't be available.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Okay.
I see.
Actually, I sent them an email to reschedule the call, but I haven't got any update yet. So, because I had another interview aligned at the same time.
For Drive, so...
But neither they replied. So that's why I have not rescheduled it. So let's see if they come.
Forgive, what was your statement on this?
On which one?
Their availability. You said you've discussed it with them.
I mean, I sent them an email if we can reschedule this call, but we haven't got any confirmation from them, like they are okay or they just want to keep it because I kept both the options. If we can reschedule or you want to keep the meeting.
Oh, for.
Forgive, I meant I meant for build it.
But.
Yeah, for Build It, Chris is traveling, I believe if I remember correctly, he's traveling to Europe during that time. So he won't be available.
Pre.
Any chance Andrea is joining?
No, I don't think they are joining because by this time, or at least Andrea joins the call. So I think they are not joining.
No, joining, joining for Build It.
No, they are not. Not this year.
Okay, so she, so she is not joining for Build It either. Okay.
Yeah, she's actually not the, she's just a dispatcher and.
I'm gonna put none.
So, Kris is the is the CEO of the CEO and everything.
It's a very small thing. Kris himself works on the tickets to the onsites.
Yeah.
Yup, understood.
I'm just trying to, just trying to grab what we have learned and why, and make sure that I'm updating this tracker accordingly. That's all.
OK, thank you.
I think we can drop off on the bridge. I don't think they are going to join today's call. I don't want to just keep you guys waiting.
Sure, appreciate that.
Yeah.
Take care. Bye bye. Have a good day. Bye bye.
Okay, thank you everyone. Bye-bye.
Okay. Catch y'all later.